searching for his son's remains
ali is devastated he says his 12 year
old was burned to death
at the imam al-hussein hospital in
southern iraq
i can't speak i can't speak may this
government be destroyed
dozens of covet 19 patients died
when fire broke out in their isolation
ward on monday
anastria is a city in mourning victims
houses
are marked with their pictures
omotiba is in shock she's lost three of
her relatives
she says two of her cousins died while
trying to rescue their father
one of my brothers lost his daughter and
young wife the other was about to get
married
their mother is in great trauma the
government has set up a commission to
investigate the incident
security officials of the akar province
acknowledged that mistakes were
committed
it's clear that negligence by the
hospital's officials led to this tragedy
we did our best to save lives but we
couldn't
relatives and friends of the victims
have been coming to
tents like this one across on asria
to offer their condolences the death is
inside a state iran hospital have
prompted
widespread public anger and mistrust
of government health institutions
angry protesters stormed the hospital
pledging to continue demonstrating until
those responsible
are brought to justice we want from a
government
um but everyone everyone who managed
them in this ministry of health in jail
the protesters chanted against impunity
threatening to take matters into their
own hands
if it continues
southern iraq